nos piden multiplicar 1.45 por 10 a la
ocho por 9.2 por diez a la menos 12 por
3.0 1 por 10 a la menos 5 y expresar el
producto tanto en notación decimal como
científica entonces tenemos 1.45 por 10
la 8 por y podría expresar esto con los
paréntesis como está indicado aquí pero
voy a usar el símbolo de multiplicación
por 9.2 por 10 a la menos 12 x 3.01 por
3.0 1 por 10 a la menos 5 cuando
encontramos expresiones de esta manera
separadas por paréntesis voy a
multiplicar esta expresión por esta
expresión por esta expresión y dado que
sólo están involucradas multiplicaciones
no importa el orden en el que
multiplicamos con eso en mente puede
intercambiar el orden aquí y esto va a
ser lo mismo que 1.45 1.45
9.2
3.01 por 3.0 1 x
y déjame hacer lo mejor en color púrpura
por 10 a la octava por 10 a la octava x
10 a la potencia menos 12 y por 10 al
menos 5 por 10 a la potencia menos 5 y
esto nos convino porque aquí puede
agrupar todas las potencias de 10 dejar
por un paréntesis aquí y aquí puede
agrupar todo lo que no es potencias de
10 y aquí puedo simplificar tengo la
misma base 10 puedo sumar los exponentes
entonces esto va a ser igual 10 a la
octava
- la potencia 12 y menos la potencia 5 y
para esto de acá déjame sacar la
calculadora tenemos que es 1.45 lo
podíamos haber hecho a mano pero es
mucho más rápido en calculadora y menos
susceptible de error por 9.2
a 3.01 y esto es igual a 40 punto 15 34
entonces tenemos 40 punto 15 34 por
supuesto por esta potencia de 10 vamos a
simplificar esto entonces va a ser igual
a 40 15 34 por 10 a la 8 menos 12 es
menos 4 menos 5 es menos 9 esto hace el
10 a la potencia menos 9 ahora podríamos
estar tentados a decir que ya está esto
en notación científica pues aquí tenemos
un número y aquí una potencia de 10 sin
embargo esto no está aún en notación
científica y esto es así pues para que
una expresiones de notación científica
este número de aquí tiene que ser mayor
o igual a 1 y menor a 10 y obviamente
este número no es menor a 10 básicamente
para que algo esté notación científica
lo que quieres es un único dígito un
punto decimal y todo el resto de los
decimales aquí no puedes tener más de
dos dígitos es un solo dígito el que
requerimos aquí obviamente aquí
tenemos dos dígitos tenemos un número
que es mayor a 10 y esto no está en
notación científica pues este número
tiene que ser menor a 10 o mayor igual a
1 entonces lo mejor que podemos hacer
aquí es escribir este número en notación
decimal
este número es igual a 4.0 1 534 por 10
y la manera de pensar en esto es que
para pasar de 40 a 4 tuvimos que correr
el punto decimal un lugar a la izquierda
dividimos entre 10 y luego compensamos
esto multiplicando por 10 dividimos
entre 10 aquí multiplicamos por 10 y no
se altera la expresión esto también lo
puedes ver como que 4 puntos y todos
estos decimales multiplicado por 10 es
igual a 40.15 34 entonces aquí tenemos
4.0 x 34 por 10 a la 110 a la 1 lo mismo
que 10 y esto está multiplicado por 10 a
la menos 9
y de nueva cuenta tenemos la misma base
podemos sumar los exponentes
así es que esto de aquí va a ser igual a
1 menos 9 va a ser 10 a la menos 8
tenemos entonces que esto va a ser igual
a 4.0 15 34 por 10 de la menos 8 y esto
de aquí ya lo tenemos en notación
científica ahora nos piden que lo
expresemos tanto en notación decimal
como científica esencialmente cuando nos
piden que lo escribamos en notación
decimal lo que queremos es hacer esta
multiplicación queremos expandir este
número y para hacer esto lo que hacemos
es le escribimos estos dígitos 40 15 34
y tomamos en consideración el punto
decimal tomados en consideración dónde
está el punto decimal ahora cada vez que
yo divido entre 10 o cada vez que
multiplicó por una potencia de 10 a la
menos 1 lo que hago es correr el punto
decimal un lugar hacia la izquierda
asciz y multiplicó por 10 a la potencia
menos 1 es lo mismo que dividir entre 10
y muevo el punto decimal un lugar así
izquierda aquí estoy multiplicando por
10 a la potencia menos 8 o podemos decir
que estamos dividiendo entre 10 a la
octava potencia entonces tenemos que
mover el punto decimal 8 lugares a la
izquierda tenemos que mover punto
decimal 8 lugares a la izquierda y una
manera de acordarse de esto es bueno
este es un número muy muy muy pequeño si
lo multiplicó por este número
voy a obtener un número muy muy muy
pequeño y por lo cual tengo que correr
el punto decimal hacia la izquierda si
este fuera 10 a la octava potencia este
sería un número muy grande y tendría
entonces que correr el punto decimal
hacia la derecha así que todo esto de
aquí deberá de resultar un número menor
que 4.0 1534 entonces mover el punto
decimal 8 lugares a la izquierda si
nuevo el punto decimal un lugar a la
izquierda lo va a obtener aquí y los
siguientes 7 lugares que mueva hacia la
izquierda los voy a llenar de ceros
entonces 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 el punto decimal
y voy a poner un cero antes del punto
decimal para mayor claridad
vamos que se incluyó este dígito vamos a
tener ocho dígitos perdón se incluyó
este dígito vamos a tener siete ceros y
este dígito ocho lugares 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
la mejor manera de pensar en esto es que
empezamos con el punto decimal aquí nos
movimos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 lugares a la
izquierda eso es lo que multiplicar por
10 a la menos 8 significa obtuvimos este
número de aquí y cuando ves un número
como estos empiezas a valorar el por qué
escribimos números en notación
científica esto es más fácil de escribir
toma menos espacio y te das una idea de
qué tan grande es el número esto es más
difícil de escribir puedes haber puesto
un cero de menos un cero de más y la
gente que lo lee tiene que contar
cuántos ceros pusiste aquí para darse
cuenta o darse una idea de qué tan
grande o qué tan pequeño es el número lo
que obtuvimos nosotros fueron 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 ceros y el cuatro es lo que
significa este menos 8 pero este número
de aquí es un número que se ve mucho más
complicado que el que obtuvimos usando
notación científica